[Musik]
prescott hallo herzlich willkommen
israels seit einer woche hier schon das
oktoberfest ortschaft dieses haben wir
jeden tag jeden abend ich weiß nicht ich
war noch nie auf dem oktoberfest
moratorium ich wollte mich einfach nur
verkleiden
ich gehe auch wünsche noch ungeschlagen
ja das ist bisher was anderes jedenfalls
habe ich euch letzte woche bereits
gezeigt wie man einen dirndl backen kann
und heute habe ich gedacht machen wir
natürlich passen dazu die lederhose aber
manch eine lederhose
da ich gar keine an der tom kam heute
ganz vorbildlich das müssen wir auch mal
zeigen
da kamen wir ganz vorne sechs kilo
lederhose rot weiß karierte übrigens
mitarbeiter des monats ja und ja
deswegen habe ich gedacht komm ich nehm
toms lederhose als vorlage und back
einfach ja seine lederhose nach so ist
es cool oder ja jetzt während dem dreh
habe mitbekommen dass unser freund
markus heute 40 wird deswegen aber
gedacht kommen dann machen wir gleich
eine komplette tag startete dann aber
werde ich gleich noch werde ich gleich
noch seinen schriftzug draufschreiben
und ja eben dann schenken das heißt kann
sich die torte heute leider nicht
probieren es ganz schlimm weil sie gar
nicht geplant wir haben jetzt machen wir
einfach so als hätten was direkt mit
eingeplant und also zwei fliegen mit
einer klappe geschlagen
markus diese torte wurde extra für dich
gemacht ja alles schon glücklich zum
vierzigsten aber ich gehe jetzt nicht um
den sonderbereich sie eben nicht so als
ich muss danach noch zum eltern ab und
weist wie die mich dann alle angucken
jedenfalls habe ich hier eine torte mit
schoko von band eingedeckt und habe
ihnen darin eine richtig leckere nuss
nugat torte und sogar noch ein bisschen
crunch mit dabei wir haben nämlich
selbst harmlos coke antrag gestellt und
das ganze mit vollmilch ghanas
eingedeckt ist wie ich mir richtig
lecker
also da ist ein richtig schöner kramm
streng du kannst jetzt hat nicht
kopieren geht es gleich zum genau und
ich zeige euch jetzt mal die zutaten für
den teig denn damit starte ich jetzt
zuerst für den teig traurig 4 200 gramm
zucker
eine prise salz und etwas vanille
extrakt 200 milliliter sonnenblumenöl
200 milliliter buttermilch sprudel oder
zum beispiel bier 300 gramm mehl 2
teelöffel backpulver 1 teelöffel zimt
150 gramm nuss nougat und 100 gramm
haselnüsse für den teig verrührt ich
zuerst die eier mit dem zucker dem salz
und dem wandel extrakt in vier bis fünf
minuten schön weiß cremig
[Musik]
in der zwischenzeit kann ich schon mal
die haselnüsse einmal und dann werden
sie in einer pfanne ohne fett gerüstet
bis sie lecker duften
jetzt meldet sich noch den nougat bei
niedriger stufe in einem kleinen topf
und dann rühre ich jetzt alle zutaten
also die buttermilch das sonnenblumenöl
das mehl gemeinsam mit den gemahlenen
haselnüssen mit dem backpulver dem
centro den nougat in den teig und dann
wird der teig nur noch ganz kurz
verrührt
[Musik]
den teig für dich jetzt in einen
vorbereiteten ba kram und den habe ich
auf größter stufe eingestellt
da wird er jetzt glatt gestrichen und
dann im vorgeheizten backofen bei 170
grad ober unterhitze für etwa 35 bis 40
minuten gebacken
der teig ist jetzt im backofen um die
zwischenzeit kann ich nutzen um einen
kanal zu stellen zudem nutzt magath
passt perfekt eine vollmilch garage
dafür koche ich 300 gramm sahne in einem
kleinen topf auf und ziehen sie dann
wieder vom herd herunter anschließend
kommen jetzt 750 gramm
vollmilchschokolade rein und dann wird
die canucks solange gerührt bis der
schokolade geschmolzen ist die kann aber
jetzt umgefüllt und da kommt jetzt ein
deckel drauf und damit sie ein bisschen
schneller abkühlt stelle ich sehr
einfach auf so einen körper kann sie
hier auf der seite stehen lassen und es
kühlt aber dann wieder wegnehmen wenn
sie schön streichfähig ist die
zwischenzeit nutze ich jetzt um einfach
ein bisschen dicker herzustellen und ich
habe jetzt hier bereits sind kate bord
das ist noch in folie eingeschweißt
daher konnte ich jetzt einfach mit einem
edding auf das skateboard drauf machen
so ganz grob damit ich weiß wie groß die
torte später sein wird und welche deko
elemente ich herstellen möchte zuerst
stelle ich jetzt die knöpfe her da habe
ich so eine silikonform und nehme jetzt
einfach modelliert schokolade weil die
wirklich super aushärtet und habt ihr
jetzt bereits weich geknetet und kann
jetzt immer kleine stücke abreißen
zusammenrollen und hier rein drücken
falls ihr keine silikonform habt zeige
ich euch gleich wie man alternativ
knüpfte herstellen kann
um die knöpfe selber herzustellen rollig
die modelle schokolade auf drei
millimeter stärke aus jetzt könnt ihr
einen kleinen ausstecher oder zum
beispiel eine spritztour nehmen die etwa
einen durchmesser von drei zentimetern
hat und damit steche ich jetzt die
knöpfe aus jetzt nehme ich eine kleinere
spritzt hülle oder einen kleineren
ausstecher mit etwa 15 cm durchmesser
und präge den knopf für eine schöne
dekoration nehme ich jetzt noch einen
kleinen blumen ausstecher und präge
damit die mieter des knopfes die kleinen
löcher können die entweder mit einem
zahnstocher oder zum beispiel mit einer
ganz kleinen loch thüle reinstecken und
jetzt müssen alle knöpfe einfach nur
noch gut aus herten
damit ich sie später verwenden kann
jetzt kommen noch die schnallen für die
lederhose dafür nehme ich jetzt schwarze
modell schokolade und auch die rolle ich
jetzt auf 3 mm stärke aus
[Musik]
das stück lege ich jetzt auf backpapier
damit ich es einfach gar nicht mehr
bewegen muss und jetzt nämlich wieder
meine vorlage damit ich weiß wie groß
ungefährlich schneidend sein müssen also
die kommen jetzt hier drauf auf die
hosenträger und ich nehme jetzt
ausstecher ihr könnt aber auch das ganze
einfach mit einem messer ausschneiden
und ich habe jetzt hier rechteckige
ausstecher einfach welche von der größe
her gut passen
[Musik]
und so sehen sie jetzt noch ein bisschen
langweilig aus daher nehme ich jetzt
hier besonders silikonform ihr könnt
aber auch das ganze ohne silikon
vormachen und jetzt einfach kleine
dekoelemente modellieren und die mit
lebensmittel kleber draufkleben
[Musik]
die deko darf jetzt trocknen und in der
zeit kann ich schon mal das mittelstück
an der lederhose machen und zwar ist es
zwischen den hosenträgern
das mache ich jetzt aus braunem schoko
von dort den nämlich später auch zum
überziehen die torte und damit es stück
aushärten kann ich da jetzt einfach ein
bisschen cmc beim verein und ich brauche
es dafür etwa 100 gramm und etwa einen
halben teelöffel cmc pulver und durch
das 10 10 pulver kann das später eben
schön aus herten
und das kann ich jetzt auch etwas becker
stärke wieder auf 3 mm stärke ausrollen
[Musik]
für den steg träger habe ich mir jetzt
eine schablone geschnitten und die kann
ich jetzt mit ein bisschen kokosfett
einfach hier draufkleben und dann mit
einem scharfen cutter zurechtschneiden
[Musik]
und jetzt nehme ich ein präge rat soll
ich hier und kann jetzt einfach die
nähte einprägen
[Musik]
die deko kann ich jetzt trocknen lassen
und kann mich jetzt um die torte kümmern
die nehme ich jetzt erst einmal aus dem
back rahmen heraus und es geht am besten
mit einem rack form messer
[Musik]
jetzt schneidet ihn einmal durch
jetzt habe ich den deckel weg genommen
und jetzt wird die torte gefüllt und
zwar habe ich jetzt hier ein bisschen
kirsch konfitüre
also es war eigentlich kirsche lee habe
ich ein bisschen erwärmt wer möchte kann
hier zum beispiel auch ein bisschen
kirschwasser zufügen und damit er die
torte ist getränkt
[Musik]
jetzt stört sich noch den deckel und
kann den auch bestreichen
[Musik]
die ghanas hat jetzt mittlerweile auch
die perfekte konsistenz ist schön
streiks fähig und da kommt jetzt auch
eine kleine schicht dies dann so etwa 3
bis 4 mm dick einfach mitten in die
torte
[Musik]
die füllung habe ich jetzt glatt
gestrichen und jetzt kommt noch ein
bisschen krank in die torte und dafür
habe ich jetzt haselnuss coke antrag
gestellt und 150 gramm haselnüsse grob
gehackt die habe ich dann in einer
pfanne ohne fett gerüstet und 50 gramm
zucker darüber gestreut und dann einfach
so lange gerührt bis der zucker
karamellisiert war dann sage ich jetzt
auf einer dauer bank folie abkühlen
lassen also komplett abkühlen lassen und
jetzt breche ich es einfach noch so in
kleine stücke und kann das jetzt als
kramp füllung hier noch mit rein geben
wichtig ist nur dass man so ein bisserl
reindrückt in die creme und dann kann
nämlich der deckel schon drauf
ich habe ich mir jetzt eine kleine
vorlage gemacht und die kann ich jetzt
auf torte drauflegen und einfach zu
schneiden
zwar sieht es jetzt aus und entweder
könnte die torte jetzt auf dem torten
retter fertig dekorieren und anrichten
oder nehmt so wie ich ein cache bord das
mache ich immer ganz gerne weil ich dann
außen rum das skateboard auch noch schön
dekorieren kann und dafür streiche ich
jetzt ein bisschen von der kanal auf das
skateboard
und wenigstens in einem stück rüber
bekommt dann zerteilt den guten mann
einfach und hebt die torte in zwei
stücken pulver
[Musik]
und jetzt kann ich die torte komplett
mit der gage eindecken und zwar kommt da
jetzt die erste schicht drauf dann muss
die torte für etwa 20 minuten in den
kühlschrank und dann die zweite schicht
die dann auch die schöne glatte schicht
wird
[Musik]
so das war jetzt so der letzte schliff
ihr könnt auch hier gerne wie bei der
torte so ein bisschen struktur natürlich
auch mit reinbringen
ich halte die torte aber relativ flach
und stellt sie jetzt für etwa einer
stunde in den kühlschrank damit die
kammer schön fest werden kann und dann
die von dort rüber kommen kann
die torte ist jetzt doch ein bisschen zu
flach deswegen nehme ich jetzt noch die
kuchen reste und habe noch mal ein
bisschen ganache gemacht vollmilch
ganache und will jetzt einfach die
kuchen reste verwenden um die torte so
ein bisschen dreidimensionaler machen
[Musik]
also soll gefällt mir jetzt viel besser
jetzt habe ich ihn auch noch mal in der
kühlung und jetzt habe ich etwa 750
gramm weißen von dann bereits weich
geknetet und den rolle hinaus und zwar
ich jetzt hier den fondant mit der
verbesserten rezeptur und zwar wurde
folgendes verändert hier ist es schwer
butter drin und auch etwas kokosöl und
dadurch kann man den von der fifa
ausrollen als auch für elastischer und
vor allem ich wirklich sehr einzigartig
also ich habe vorher noch nie in anderen
fordern gesehen mit cher butter am
anfang beim kneten ist ein bisschen
härter aber dann wird super geschmeidig
und wirklich so elastisch und man kann
so lasst so dünn ausrollen wie papier
ohne dass er reist also wirklich sehr
elastisch
[Musik]
torte fertig jetzt mit etwas sagt renz
drin
so hatte davon dann besser dran wenn
jetzt kann ich ihnen darüber legen
ich habe ihnen das nicht ganz dünn
ausgerollt sondern etwa 23 mm dick damit
einfach dass brown nicht durchschimmert
gastiert überlegen und hier unten weil
dies nicht komplett bedecken
da kommt eine schicht darüber für die
lederhose mit einfach schön mit und
henrik glatt streichen und gleich
benutze ich noch wandern klettern
[Musik]
jetzt kann ich hier den unteren teil
wegschneiden denn da kommt jetzt gleich
fondant drauf
[Musik]
den job von dann schneide ich jetzt hier
schon mal gerade dann habe ich gleich
ein bisschen einfacher legen drüber und
passieren dann auch mit den händen an
[Musik]
und ihm ist da jetzt im prinzip nur
zwischen den beinen so ein bisschen
aufpassen und gucken dass er von dort
nicht reißt das heißt einfach mit den
fingern vergleich das ist einfach ganz
vorsichtig mit den fingern eben schon
klatschen
jetzt habe ich noch mal ein bisschen
schoko von damit ganz dünn ausgerollt
da schneide ich jetzt einmal ein band zu
das wird dann der bund und das klebe ich
jetzt einfach mit etwas essbarem kleber
an
[Musik]
hier werde jetzt auch wieder die nähte
eingeprägt dann kommt jetzt hier vorne
seine tasche hin also so wie beim tom
auf der hose und das müsste jetzt
einfach ein bisschen nach augenmaß haben
ich habe halt ein echt modell dar
wenn ihr das nicht hat müsste einfach
eure mann oder eurem freund eine
lederhose kaufen und dann musste er sich
einfach auch in die kirche stellen und
denken wir beim abkochen
[Musik]
ich habe ich jetzt noch einen kragen
angebracht und zwar habe ich dafür weiß
wovon dann mit ein bisschen cnc prüfe
verknetet ihr könnt aber zum beispiel
auch blüten passte nehmen und dann
einfach ein langes band zu schneiden und
das ganze schön ankleben
ich dachte das hemd jetzt nicht weiß
sondern mache ein rot weiß rot weiß
kariertes karohemd und dafür nehme ich
jetzt einfach ein bisschen
lebensmittelfarbe ihr könnt das ganze
jetzt entweder mit farbstiften auf mag
dafür muss davon dann ein bisschen
vorher an getrocknet sein oder ihr könnt
auch pulver farbe vermischen entweder
mit bisschen wasser trocknet es nicht
ganz so gut oder können doch alkohol
nehmen dafür fliegt das ganze ein
bisschen schneller
[Musik]
jetzt lebe ich das mittelstück hier an
es kann jetzt kurz antrocknen und dann
habe ich auch schon mal die träger
vorbereitet
[Musik]
ich habe mich jetzt hier außen dran
kleben
jetzt kann ich auch die einzelnen
elemente wie zum beispiel die kleinen
knöpfe ankleben und am ende kommt noch
das schöne ordner mensch drauf die deko
teile sind jetzt getrocknet und das was
jetzt hier aussieht wie der bilderrahmen
ist natürlich die schnalle die kommt
gleich hier dran aber die möchte ich
noch ein bisschen verschönern und
deswegen nehme ich jetzt metallic farbe
und kann dir jetzt hier drauf streichen
[Musik]
die schneiden sehen jetzt durch das gold
und silber so ein bisschen alt aus was
ich sehr hübsch finde und jetzt gebe ich
sie an mich muss bei dir gucken wo für
mich erhöhe ich mache so geführt die
höhe und habe ich nochmal die
hosenträger gemacht und so ein bisschen
gekürzt natürlich auch mit löchern und
hier unten schönen spitz zugeschnitten
und die kann ich jetzt hier dran kleben
und darf aber auch nicht vergessen hier
in der mitte noch im loch einzuprägen
[Musik]
ich habe ich jetzt noch mal aus
schwarzer modell der schokolade den
stift gemacht den muss ich jetzt ein
bisschen zu schneiden und dann einfach
hier dran kleben
[Musik]
und jetzt nämlich noch weiße pulver
farbe die habe ich jetzt auch schon
angerührt und werde jetzt mit einem
dünnen pinsel einfach noch die motive
auf die lederhose malen
[Musik]
jetzt ist die torte fertig jetzt muss
ich noch das skateboard über 10
und dafür habe ich jetzt einfach banane
voller genommen hat nämlich eine schöne
so ein bisschen frischer farbe und damit
kann ich jetzt das skateboard eindecken
ich habe es jetzt bereits mit kleber
bestrichen und jetzt lege ich das
einfach drauf und kann es dann mit
module werkzeug noch ein bisschen muster
[Musik]
um das brett hier so ein bisschen zu
strukturieren nehme ich einfach einen
zahnstocher
wobei ich hab jetzt steckt spielst und
denen drücke ich einfach in den weichen
von den beiden ja so sieht jedenfalls
setzt die torte aus und ich muss sagen
sie gefällt mir auch sehr gut und auch
nicht zu schwer nachzumachen
ich muss echt eine schöne einfache torte
die denke ich auch jeder hinbekommt
bischen was ist ehrlich jetzt gebraucht
wieder ja vielleicht 150 stunden ist
okay mit wartezeit hat man muss halt
zwischendurch ein bisschen warten
in der zeit haben wir pizza gegessen das
war auch okay gemacht toni war da er
geschimpft er hat gesagt das ist eine
badische pizzas waren keine italienische
pizza wieso sollte das wissen ja dass
man halt die tomatensauce mit stunden
lang gekocht haben
naja was solls jedenfalls ist diese
torte fertig wir können sie leider nicht
probieren ich werde sie gleich bei
markus probieren und die seiner familie
bringen
ich schreibe einfach noch kurz und
schriftzug drüber tatsächlich gleich
noch zwei drei bilder im anschluss und
ich hoffe dass euch dieses video
gefallen hat hier mit muss ich leider
schon unsere oktoberfest woche beenden
also murat a
aber wenn es der sache damit kann ich
jetzt einmal die woche für dich am 10
also ich wünsche euch viel spaß beim
nachhaken
das rezept können übrigens noch
nachlesen auf salehs welt.de und ich
freue mich schon aufs nächste mal bis
dann
es macht viel spaß
[Musik]